mari Anki tell me about your experience  working with Mathias Kona it's making  Rustin Boehm well I didn't know much yes  before we met the first time because we  we were at Jack's house for a reading  and first of all when I saw him eyes I  thought my god he's a magnificent huge  male guy I mean and and then he started  reading and I expected Jack to choose an  amazing actor but it was beyond my  expectations and what kind of research  and preparation did you do for playing a  character he's a double amputee well I  have to say usually I really need to  work very deeply into to research a lot  and I started to research I started to  watch footage of people who who have no  legs and and I felt that it was that I  didn't need it because it just happened  in my character's life and I thought  that I would feel and learn if I can use  this word with her  you